TK: I'm Tom Kornberg. I'm on the faculty at UCSF in the Cardiovascular Research Institute,
where I actually work on fruit flies. EA: ...Drosophila, just in case you didn't know what it was called.
And I'm Emanuel Ax, who has nothing to do with flies, or fruit for that matter,
but we do make music together and we're old classmates.
I was I guess mainly a music major and you were a music and science major.
TK: To be fair we were classmates at Columbia College. We were also classmates at the Juilliard School,
which was at that time right across the street. So that does date us.
EA: That's true, that's true. ...Well, the building is still there.
TK: But I would say that I was a Columbia student, who took performance classes:
Orchestra, Chamber Music and lessons at Juilliard. You really were a Juilliard student...
EA: ... who took classes at Columbia, including a biochemistry course. Which was very exciting.
TK: You used some textbook, which you....
EA: I used the Watson textbook "The Molecular Biology of the Gene,"
which I still think is the best textbook I've ever seen about anything.
Because I picked up the book and I actually understood something.
And I think with that subject it's a miracle.
I must say I'm totally dazzled by the fact that you've kept up your playing so wonderfully.
And I wish I could come do research with you the way you play with me.
TK: So over the years since we were students, your travels, your tours
have frequently brought you to San Francisco.
And on the occasions where the time has permitted
we've enjoyed getting together to play chamber music. EA: Right.
TK: And so this is a special pleasure after all these years to be doing something really serious...
EA: Well, the pleasure is all mine.
And I guess we're going to do the first movement of the Beethoven cello Sonata in A major, opus 69.
TK: Allegro ma non troppo. EA: If you say so!
Sonata...